happy Star Wars week everybody you made
it we got new Star Wars footage let's
break this down
first things first it's time for the
Jedi to end I know everybody's freaking
out about that but there is like a rogue
one giveaway that I'm doing a viewing
way a blu-ray all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber or leave a
comment on this video I'll be doing a
whole bunch of Star Wars videos it's
gonna take us the rest of the year to
talk about what's gonna be happening to
the Jedi but let's go through this shop
by shot so you immediately pick up in
the moments after episode 7 ends they
said that they meant to do that but this
does jump forward just a little bit to
when she starts training with flu he
talks her through some of the basic Jedi
skills listen breathe here with the
forces telling you there's a lot of
shots of her walking around auch - you
get different shots of the islands so it
seems like a lot of the first act of the
film has them spent here with her
meeting her hero and she said something
really interesting - she said there's
this thing about meeting your heroes in
being slightly disappointed expectations
not being met so that might be referring
to the big tag at the end where she's
like oh my god the Jedi are real han
Solo told us all the myths are true and
then Luke coming right out and saying
the only thing I know that's true is
that the Jedi needs and and her just
being like oh my god what the hell just
happened
this shot of her using the force with
the rocks rising up around her this was
part of the footage they showed off at
that Disney investor meeting that you
might have heard about and I love that
as she says she sees light and darkness
you go from this new shot of Belaya and
then to kylo ren's
smashed helmet so when you zoom in if
you can't tell what's going on here
these are a bunch of old books it looks
like this is part of the temple that
Luke's searching for they're searching
for the origins of the force it would be
like finding a holy book that describes
your religion this is an original
version in not a copy of a copy times a
thousand that's one of the big problems
with the force and what Luke's probably
talking about the Jedi need to end
because their doctrine is a copy of a
copy of a copy and things have been lost
in the translation so he's trying to get
back to the origins of the force Mark
Hamill was very cryptic about the
backstory of Luke when we get to Episode
seven in Episode eight Kathleen Kennedy
was like no no no he's huge but the
funny thing that Easter Egg here for the
EU if you haven't read the expanded
universe
you don't remember the Dark Horse Comics
is there was a planet called Isis with a
giant world tree where they would keep a
lot of lightsabers and Jedi lore so
that's not where this is but this seems
like an easter egg for that so they like
to invoke a lot of EU even if the actual
story is something new that they're
developing shown right after the
implication of this symbol though is
that this is the true original symbol of
the Jedi so it seems like kylo Ren and
Snoke are also searching for this
information too and that's what this
flash scene is that she gets when she
touches the lightsaber there were a lot
of people wandering after episode 7 what
happened but JJ Abrams the producers
later came out and said that this is
technically not a flashback like this
isn't when he comes to kill the Jedi
Temple that Luke was running the Rey
talks about light dark and balanced so
it seems like they'll be finding a new
balance Bendu style there won't be the
Ben do from rebels he's not gonna be in
the movie but the ideas that he teaches
but it sounds like they're Rhys entering
the idea of the force between the light
side and the dark side so that means
that there's a whole bunch of potential
new powers that you'll see them used
because there were so many things that
were off-limits to the Jedi that they
wouldn't touch because it involved dark
side emotions but really it's all just
in the interpretation in the intent so
that's what he means when he says it's
also much bigger and I love this wide
shot of her just swinging Anakin's the
lightsaber
around as he's standing there on the
cliff just kind of watching her we get a
shot of the resistance going up against
the first order it looks a little bit
like Hoth but this is the Mars like
planet with red soil that they were
talking about this was also shown off in
that investor footage so the new walkers
if you couldn't tell they call them
gorilla walkers it's like an extra big
extra cool-looking version of an
old-school 8080 loving all these new
ship designs even though it's invoking a
lot of the classic trilogy all this
looks so much more different from the
other films and what's come before then
episode 7 did this looks like Finn
relatively early in the movie still
healing from kylo Ren's injury he
slashed his spine so I mean that's not
something that you just walk away from
Poe and bb-8 running through a Corvette
that looks like it's under heavy fire
from the first order they did say that
the first order would be jumping on the
power vacuum now that they destroyed
most of the New Republic and even though
they lost their Starkiller base the
galaxy is in more cave
than ever before the first order is all
about that
so the first act of the film while ray
is off training with Luke they are going
to be making hard moves to take control
still gotta love his x-wing I love the
way that he has one of the only black X
wings that's really just to make it
stand out on screen so you recognize it
when he's flying around but he's also
the best pilot in the resistance wedge
style I'd say that Luke was the best
pilot in the rebellion not expecting it
but it would be really cool to see Luke
pilot in x-wing too because his ability
in the force also makes him a much
better pilot back on the Falcon which is
still in Rey's possession then heard
charging on a planet with Anakin's
lightsaber Lex is charging into battle
she's wearing her new costume - like
this is new tunic that she has on this
kylo Ren shot is cut out of order but
you can kind of see the scar running
down his forehead so like we saw the
smashed helmet it seems like he'll be
walking around without the helmet he
might get another version but I think
the implication here is that in the
first movie you're meant to get this big
reveal like oh he looks like this young
boy underneath it he's just this
innocent looking person who seems like
he could go either really evil or really
good but nope turns out he's evil
because he killed his father so now that
mask has fully come off and he will be
hardcore evil in this movie regardless
of what you think his arc is or where he
might end up in episode 9 this almost
looks like a companion shot from the
first trailer where we see Luke's hand
touch r2d2 like he is kneeling down this
almost seems like it's the same scene
cut from a different angle in him
watching his Jedi Temple burned down so
they will at least be explaining a
little bit about the prehistory of
episode 7 and what's happened to the
Jedi and I love the way phasma rolls up
here through the smoke it's almost like
this shot of White Walkers from Game of
Thrones if you don't watch it Gwendoline
Christie just a big game of Thrones
character with a very similar shot from
the previous season the white shot of
the resistance fighting the first order
as we saw in the earlier shot with them
going into battle a lot of these ship
designs look vastly different from stuff
that we've seen before so a couple
things that we don't see in the trailer
at least outright one is the brand-new
character played by Kelly Marie Tran her
name is supposed to be roast she's like
a maintenance worker who doesn't want to
be a hero she just happened to find
herself in the resistance and she gets
swept up in the adventure through fin
and Poe's character so she's supposed to
be a really
small physically small character who is
really big in the story in the really
cool Easter Egg for Episode seven is
that her character's name is Rose and
they did confirm that but during the
filming of episode seven maz kanata's
name was actually Rose on set they use a
lot of fake names for characters when
they're filming but I love the way that
they use maz kanata's fake name for her
real name in there both small physical
characters even though they're really
big in the story so if you were
wondering though Maz Kanata did survive
episode 7 it was just some deleted
footage that showed her arriving at the
resistance base so she is still alive in
the universe but let me know what you
guys think of this this is so great I
love the tease it just gives you an idea
of some of the things happening in the
movie the idea of them searching for the
origins of the force really the thing
that blows me away the most in addition
to the visual design of all the new
starships is the idea of these force
Bible books that are supposedly hidden
somewhere maybe on this Ock 2 planet but
the real big thing we got to talk about
though is that how they're going to
recenter the force like the whole idea
the prophecy of anakin the one who will
bring balance to the force was the idea
that the Jedi had gone in this really
bad direction so the midi-chlorians if
you want to call him that we don't have
to talk about midi-chlorians wanted to
balance that out by creating anakin
skywalker so that he was sort of even
the scales but he really just tipped
things back in the direction of evil in
the Sith so we could talk about how that
might be an incomplete version of
balance maybe that's something for
another video so we'll talk about the
prophecy of the one who will bring
balance in another video believe all
your requests for new Star Wars videos
I'll be posting a whole bunch more panel
stuff in bonus videos for the rest of
the weekend so while you wait for that
you can click here for the panel the
behind the scenes and you can click here
for that funny video of mace windu and
Liam Neeson thank you so much for
watching let's high five I'll see you
guys in the next video
you
[Music]